PROFESSOR: Now,
what should happen?
Somehow, this
equation probably has
solutions for all
values of the energy,
but those solutions diverge
and are not normalizeable.
It's the kind of thing you will
find with a shooting method
that you're doing
with your computer.
Count the solution and
it suddenly diverges up
or diverges down and
cannot be normalized.
But for some specific
values, it can be normalized.
So what we need is an intuition
why this differential equation
has normalizeable solutions,
only if the energies, curly E,
take specific values.
That's intuition that we need.
For that, we'll look at the
equation a little closer,
and try to understand what
happens at the place where
it can get in trouble, which
is large X. That's where you
expect it to get in trouble.
So what does this
equation become as u
goes to plus minus infinity?
Well this equation, at that
stage, becomes like this.
The second phi, the u squared is
roughly equal to u squared phi.
Because e is a constant,
it doesn't blow up,
so the differential
equation, the terms
that are supposed to be largest
in this right hand side,
is the u squared.
So how does this
look as a solution?
And you can see that
that's definitely not
like a power solution.
If you have a power of u,
say phi equals u to the n,
after u differentiates,
the power goes down.
But here it goes up.
You have a u to the end.
The relative is supposed to
give you u to the n plus 2,
but that doesn't work.
So that's not a power solution.
So it has to be different.
So what it is,
you can try a phi.
And what it should be is of
the form e to the u squared.
It's kind of like that,
because this is the function
that when you're
differentiate, you
bring down the derivative of
this quantity, which is a u.
When you differentiate
again, you
can bring another u
to get the u squared,
or you can
differentiate this one.
But if you differentiate the
thing that is in the bottom,
you get something
that diverges less.
So morally speaking, this
function is about right.
So I'll put here, for example,
e to the alpha over 2.
And I'll even put here a uk.
Can this work?
A u to the k times
alpha u squared.
Well if we take two derivatives,
if we take one derivative,
if I differentiate the u to the
k, I get u to the k minus 1.
I lose powers of u.
If I differentiate
the exponential,
I can get alpha times u
times the same function.
See, that's, roughly
speaking, what's happening.
You differentiate the thing
that diverges the most.
So if you differentiate
twice, each time
you differentiate you get
a factor of alpha times u
squared phi, roughly.
This is plus subleading.
When you differentiate
a function
and you're wanting to show
the most divergent thing, then
you--
because we're looking at
the most divergent part,
you will always differentiate
this, and this u to the k
is really a spectator,
it doesn't do anything,
because when you differentiate
that, you get something much
smaller, that doesn't matter.
So yes, with these exponentials,
we get something like this.
Beside double pronged
should have been here.
And therefore, you see
that alpha is plus minus 1.
Alpha is plus minus
1, and those are
likely to be
approximate solutions
as x goes to infinity.
So we could expect solutions
for alpha equals 1,
and I will write that it,
and all this, I should say
is always as u goes to infinity.
So always as u go to infinity,
all of this in this blackboard.
So also as u go to infinity,
we would expect maybe solutions
of the form A u to
the k, e to the minus
u squared over 2 plus B u to
the k e to the u squared over 2.
The two values of alpha
equal plus minus 1
are the possibilities for
these two equations to match.
So you would expect things
like this to be solutions.
And here you are seeing the
beginning of the danger.
Well a minus u
squared over 2 times
a power sounds pretty good,
but a u squared over 2 times
a power sounds pretty bad.
So maybe this is what
we want to happen.
This is not an exact
solution of anything yet.
We're just looking at u going
to plus and minus infinity,
and maybe we'll have such a
behavior or such behavior.
But we want this one,
otherwise we will never
be able to normalize it.
So here it is.
Without any loss of generality
and inspired by this,
this analysis is absolutely
crucial, you see,
we're following a very
logical procedure.
Cleaning the
equation then looking
where the divergence
would happen
and learning something about
the form of the solution.
Now without any loss of
generality, I can write,
I will write 5x
is going to be a--
not of x anymore.
U, h of u times e to the
minus u squared over 2.
So it's an an sat, but it's
without any loss of generality,
because you can always write
any function as another function
times e to the minus u over 2,
because you take the function,
you multiply by e
to the plus u over 2
and e to the minus u over 2
and it's written like that.
But this should be nice,
because it has sort
of the right behavior already.
And here is the hope.
The hope is that this function
now is a proxy for phi.
If you know h, you know
phi, which is what you want.
And this function,
hopefully, won't diverge.
This will be into [INAUDIBLE].
So if this function
doesn't diverge,
it will be a great thing.
In particular, we could hope
that h of u is a polynomial.
You see, if somebody
with have come and said,
look at that equation.
Could that be a polynomial?
A polynomial is something
that ends up to some power
x to the 20 or x to the 30,
but it doesn't go up forever.
An exponential has all powers.
This equation doesn't have
a polynomial solution.
No polynomial will
ever solve this.
But now that you've
isolated the divergence,
there is a hope that a
polynomial will work.
So for doing that,
exploring that hope,
I now have to substitute--
this is no assumption--
the differential
equation for phi
implies a differential
equation for h,
you just substitute
this and look at it.
That's a one line computation
or two line computation.
I'll give the answer.
So what is the differential
equation for h?
So back in star, you'll
get the second h,
the u squared minus 2u dh du
plus e minus 1h equals zero.
So you substitute that
into this equation
and you get this
differential equation.
And now this is a
differential equation for h.
We hope it has a
polynomial solution.
You will see that it wants to
have a polynomial solution,
but it doesn't quite make it.
And then you will discover
quantization helps,
and suddenly you get the other
normal solution and everything
works out.